hello Israeli forces have shot and
killed at least 10 Palestinians in a
raid in the occupied West Bank City of
nablos more than a hundred other
Palestinians were injured this brings
the number of Palestinians killed by
Israeli forces this year to 61. nearly a
thousand others have been detained since
January Ibrahim is covering the story
she's joining us from nablos so have
these raids ended or are they still
going on
[Music]
the reads have ended which have enabled
Palestinians to pull the bodies of Two
fighters that we're here in this house
behind me I'm gonna step away from the
picture so you can have a look this is
where two fighters with when the Israeli
forces raided the old city of nablis and
they've surrounded the house now we've
listened into one of the voice notes
that were sent by one of the fighters he
was saying to people to continue the
fighting he was saying that he's going
in the footsteps of what he called the
martyrs who were fighting the Israeli
forces now also a third Palestinian
fighter was shot nearby this house and
the raid not only claimed the lives of
these Fighters but also
six or seven other Palestinians making
the death toll of today's rate to 10
Palestinians were waiting for the
funerals to take place here in Annapolis
let's not forget that nablis and Janine
have been the epicenter of the Israeli
raids in the past year because in these
two cities there are armed men who say
that they feel that they were left alone
by the World by their leaders and
they're taking up arms to fight Israel
it's stressing that this is the only
language that Israel understands so
along with the at least 10 Palestinians
killed and a hundred have been injured
in this raid what kind of injuries have
they sustained
the majority of those who were injured
in the beginning of the raid were shot
by live ammunition ammunition which
explains the high number of Palestinians
who were killed with hearing stories
from people here that the Israeli forces
were shooting at the neighbors here uh
people in their houses people going
about their lives The Raid took place at
10 A.M in the morning local time which
is a time when Palestinians go out and
about to go to buy things from the
market here in the old city so we've
heard that one person was going to buy
bread a 72 year old when he was shot and
killed by Israeli forces so Palestinians
say that Israel is acting because it
doesn't it's not being held accountable
that it's having a free hand killing
Palestinians and many here would tell
you that they would be considered as
collateral but for every Palestinian
family every the law of one person is
one too many and we're talking already
about 61 Palestinians who were killed
since the beginning of the year and
we're still in February 61 Palestinians
were killed by Israeli forces since the
beginning of 2023.
okay Nida thank you so much for bringing
us that update from Nablus in the
occupied West Bank where these raids
have been taking place by Israeli forces
Let's cross over to West Jerusalem
that's where Sarah hirat is joining us
from so Sarah what more is being said
about these raids and is there any
reaction to them
there definitely has been in the last
half now from the Israeli uh Security
Forces now what they're saying is that
they entered nablis they said that they
took out three Palestinians that were
wanted as part of a group of uh Fighters
Palestinian Fighters all 24 they said
that they had been behind several
attacks against their forces and they
also added that they had some more
attacks that were being planned and in
that time there was a firing between
both and that's how they ended up
killing all three wanted Palestinian men
we have reached out to them and asked
more in for more information about a
60-something-year-old that was also
killed during that time but we're still
yet to hear back from them and we've
also been hearing from Hamas which is
the arms group that's governing the Gaza
Strip and in that statement they've said
that they're losing patience and they're
watching the situation in occupied West
Bank very closely now the statement is a
strong statement because of the
escalation that's been happening here in
this year since the new government that
has come into power and we could
potentially expect Rockets being fired
out of Gaza right and put this into
context for us because what we've heard
from the new right wing Israeli
government Sarah is that they do plan to
increase raids in the occupied West Bank
that's correct this is a new government
that's barely been in power for two
months under prime minister Benjamin
Netanyahu who's come back to Power with
a coalition government that is a far
right government it's an ultra
nationalist ultra-orthodox government
that is very much in uh pushing for fast
measures especially when it comes to the
Palestinian issue now since they've come
into power there have been three attacks
one that was carried out as the
synagogue and one that was carried
outside uh where there was a bus stop
and several people had been killed now
the Israeli government says that these
raids that they're carrying out and a
lot of these demolitions are related to
that and in fact just last week they
even uh said that nine outposts will be
legalized that means more expansion of
its settlements in occupied territories
and the approval of 10 000 homes in a
rare statement from the US they've
condemned those that expansion and the
and Israel has sent said that they will
put a temporary pause for a while but
what we're seeing on the ground uh daily
raids daily demolitions while that is to
some degree in keeping with Israeli
policy but definitely tensions have been
set up since last year and all of those
measures also include for example
revoking citizenship of people that are
deemed as terrorists anyone that's in
prison including those that they say are
supporters and lots of those families
and members who are under house arrest
even are saying that this is just
Collective punishment and with the
situation and with the tensions arising
especially with Ramadan coming up soon
um they're feeling that Israel is
certainly escalating the situation we've
been seeing a lot of that happening also
in occupied East Jerusalem just a few
days ago at one of the checkpoints
children teachers being stopped from
being able to go through those
checkpoints with children having their
clothes taken off so some of these
policies actually go a against
international law for example with
demolitions and leaving people homeless
on the street okay Sarah thank you so
much for the time being and that is a
live picture from Nablus in the occupied
West Bank the Israeli raids have now
ended uh the Palestinians that have been
killed at least 10 of them killed by
Israeli forces will now be buried and uh
people are out in the city of Nablus as
you can see in in the live picture right
there
is a senior Palestine correspondent at
the news website mondawis and she
explains why Israeli forces have been
targeting Nablus in particular
for the Israeli military and the Israeli
government Annapolis
um The Old City in specific as well as
Janine refugee camp is where the
concentration of armed resistance has
been growing and Rising even though it
is expanding to other areas of the West
Bank the Lions then
um and the Janine Brigade out of Janine
refugee camp continued to be the
epicenter of Palestinian armed
resistance and new youth groups um
fighting which is why they've become a
Target the Palestinian Authority has
released letters of condemnation against
the military incursion happening on
Nablus but we also need to recall that
last year the Palestinian Authority had
arrested two Palestinians under the
suspicion of being part of the Lion's
Den group so the the Palestinian
Authority is doing what it does best
which is symbolic statements as an
official body but in terms of protection
of Palestinians that that does not exist
right now the assault on us today was
through not just the military it was
also Israeli intelligence groups and
undercover officers from the musadi bean
unit and these are civilian intelligence
these are intelligence agents um that
dress as civilians Arab civilians and
specific to Target and assassinate
Palestinians